this will be an organized match playing
another chess streamer uh who's also
live
the link is in the chat and
uh we'll both be commentating i actually
think they
like they have some commentators on
their channel uh grandmaster axel
bachmann might be commentating
um i i should i should know all the
information
uh there's a format command we'll be
playing a combination
of five minutes three minutes
and one minute
[Music]
oh
yeah i
am what i eat i haven't had sauce lately
trying to think the last type of sauce i
had a salad
oh i got a salad from whole foods it has
like this nice dill
dill dressing but salad dressing isn't
really sauce
i guess it's sauce that you put on salad
i had a very good moment in scrabble
yesterday
i played i still know how to how to
pronounce it rui it's like a french
it's a french word but it means
like a peppery sauce it was a bingo
scored a lot of points for it
eric rosen international master
in north america how's it going
i think my camera is my camera just out
of focus i think so
oh i don't know i mean i don't think
anybody in the stream right now can see
it either way
um i don't know if marcelo is gonna yeah
he's fixing it now
okay but yeah eric we we really really
appreciate you uh joining us
to um do this match i mean it's really
it's awesome of you
to support this channel we are all huge
fans i've been a
oop wait what just happened ah
i did something join
wait okay he's back he's back sorry
about that
you were saying nice things somehow i it
just
no no it's okay it's okay so much so i'm
even eating thai foods today in honor of
you oh i love thai food
yeah but no thank you thank you very
much for
uh for joining us today thank you for
for agreeing to this
match rodrigo has been very excited he's
been training this whole week
because he wants to do the best that he
can um you know
i i told him that you would go easy on
him and maybe but then afterwards that
was it you know
no hold far yeah no i'm looking forward
it look forward to it it should be it
should be a fun match
i'll say i haven't really done so much
preparation other than like taking a
walk
and playing scrabble
i was laughing so hard last night
because rodrigo was
you know booking it up and and he's
studying and practicing so hard in
preparation for the match and you were
playing scrabble and that was that
i was dying of the injustice there
but uh cool man so does anybody have any
other questions for
eric well uh hi hi eric i'm marcelo
hey how's it going rodrigo fine thanks
and
no with rodrigo we are you know the
creators of this channel and
we all the two of us want to say you
thank you very much
for accepting this invitation this match
and it's a real pleasure and honor
on having you on our channel and playing
some games with you
oh it's my pleasure yeah looking forward
to it do you guys do you guys have a
youtube channel too i i have a command
in my chat that links to your twitch
channel
but if you have youtube i can link to
that as well
yeah yeah we have a youtube also yeah ah
okay is it the same name
exactly yeah okay i'll add that to my
command
and people in my chat can check out you
guys and maybe watch both at once too we
appreciate that we really appreciate it
thank you very much it's a pleasure
yeah it should be fun have fun yeah okay
please please go easy
don't go easy eric don't go easy at all
sometimes i go easy by accident and i
can't help it
or i'll just blend your stuff if i do go
easy it won't be intentional
fair enough so we'll see what happens
are you guys going to have me on on your
stream the whole time because i can try
and fix this focus thing
if you'd like um
if you're not gonna if you're not
planning to i won't bother with it but i
know it's kind of annoying that uh
i'm completely blurred i don't know why
we have a link to your channel and uh in
the chat as well so
i mean everybody you're you're a living
legend so everybody's gonna do with your
channel so
oh i i appreciate that yeah um
well uh yeah hopefully i can spread some
some love to
your guys's channel as well so thank you
eric
thank you very much yeah my pleasure so
we'll have like a post
match like interview hopefully with you
that would be great okay
awesome yeah sounds good hopefully no
one gets too too hurt
so
we started prepping him with uh some uh
some suspicious liquids that he's been
in
drinking so oh like tea
tea yeah exactly
all right eric thank you all right yeah
good luck
cool good luck eric thank you thanks
uh 5-0 so it's six games of 5-0
uh we'll make it rated random color
i'm gonna close out of their stream uh i
might hide the chat too
hopefully there's at least some mod here
okay um
okay well good luck i'll have the chat
open
and we'll get going or this this chat
open
but i'm hiding hiding the twitch chat at
least during the game
okay
oh not sure how serious they
they mean when they like they say he's
been preparing
so i guess i'll get a sense like if he's
if he's prepared for the london
and this is all like predictable so far
um yeah the main line i think he plays a
london too
i i checked a little bit of his openings
but nothing like too in-depth probably
prepared for like half hour
just to get a sense of what to expect i
was more expecting king's indian
okay so this is like the main kind of
critical position
black has a lot of options here black
has e6 bishop g4
takes queen b6 g6
even knight h5 queen b6 is uh
a main line
yeah the more critical line is queen
diggs b2
green takes e5 um yeah this is still
prep
so the idea is to play c4 and then
eventually
b4
um i'm feeling comfortable because it's
clear that
my opponent's not prepared for this
exact variation
um
but it's not anything like
much much better but it is pleasant
let's go lavend
1120 thanks for subbing let's go
yeah i'm gonna try and con conserve as
much time as possible
if i'm familiar with the opening um idea
probably idea to play rook c1
um
what else and the drawback for lack of
this queen is a little bit awkward
leave some tension
oh there's probably a threat to take no
it's leaving
the rook let's go oh irwin smith
thanks for the lead scuba bits
okay so i'm kind of getting what i
wanted the queen side space
uh what else
in black move the queen already three
times
now it's a question if i want to go for
like c5 there's an interesting line c5
queen d8 b5
i really want to be bold
not entirely sure
i could also just kind of chill play
bishop e2
so c5 queen okay it's concrete c5 queen
d8 b5
mine has to move here or here
it just feels like a little bit kind of
overextending
i think i'll just play bishop e2 we'll
leave the tension if black ever takes
i'm
happily capturing with a knight i'll
castle
to do queen b6 or queen b3 queen b3
looks decent
i don't think i'm scared of this move
this is one of the box resources
but then d5 would be falling
now it's still a question if i want to
play c5
let's start with this we're expecting
rook to
h3 oh no rook t oh rook d8 c5
oh
so the rook can't actually go to the
square because it would get in the way
of the queen
and it's important to note my queen's
defended
so there's no like 95 trickies or
trixies
tricks tricks forgot how to say words
thanks for subbing by the way play h3
at this point it's kind of just a
waiting game
um i have a very nice time time
advantage
up by almost two minutes
a6 is logical
um so now it's a question
[Music]
i could consider you can consider
taking and playing this let's do that
it takes with pawn then i'm
i'll be able to play against the
isolated queen's pawn
it takes with knight then this was a
plan
there's this weird line takes takes
takes i think that's good for me i win
the queen i attack the rook in the end
hey it's bobo slim playing in the u.s
collegiate rapid and blitz this
weekend watching how did you know that i
was taking this
lecture to muscle up thanks
oh that's good to hear good luck get
some rest
like make sure you're in like peak
mental and physical form
[Music]
because those types of events you have
to be super focused
of this move and probably just this
keep the bishop active
okay so now rt8 is playable
um
actually not sure what to do here i'm
thinking just 95
we're probably going to end up trading
i mean in some sense like the structure
is somewhat symmetrical
i mean the main difference is i have a
bit more active queen
uh but it's very similar it's probably
close to equal
now the biggest difference is time
though so i just want to play solidly
keep the pressure i want to keep
creating moments where
my opponent has to make a decision
um
i'm sensing tactics here
because i can take and then
not e4 maybe just bishop f3 just
increase tension even more you might end
up trading
there's no increment which
is nice
that queen bee it was a good move
i wonder can i get away with with taking
oh there's a cool line okay let's take
first and then take here
i think i'm just winning material
actually it's a little bit complicated
but if takes i take here
takes and i take and fork everything
otherwise if takes i take and defend
and also hit the pawn
if takes takes here
oh there's a funny move in the end at
this after it takes
takes takes takes bishop c2 almost saves
black but i've worked he won
the counter pin
oh that's not happening oh this is a
funny line too
because i can take and then take
and then if rook takes time mate
um king h8 was good
okay let's just play quickly and not
blunder anything
bishop c2 i still have rook c1
oh thanks for the bits pushy pawn
uh play this move okay
solid game
yeah very solid game felt like i managed
my time well kept up the pace
oh i actually didn't prepare against e4
i i have no idea what my poem plays i
prepared against london
oh i should have prepared this
okay i'm just reverting to my time off
maybe at some point i'll play a stafford
maybe in the three minutes
a6
i'm gonna play i'm gonna attempt to play
like a solid line
yeah put the bishops like so
yeah this is playable
i'll admit i don't really know so much
theory here i just know this idea
um i don't think white's playing the
most like challenging line
there's other lines where like g4 g5
happens
or there's something like knight f5 p
sucks
um it's still a little bit uncomfortable
though
hmm thanks for subbing
what is my plan here what's my plan
maybe my opponent was was preparing this
um
hmm
i guess knight a7 to b5
so the whole the whole issue is my
bishop so my knight was taking the swear
that my bishop on 302 and my bishop
is taking the square my knight wants to
go to so i'm i'm
trying to solve the source of the
problem
by by putting my knight somewhere weird
but i want to play knight b5 maybe
exchange and pressure the c file
so there's some logic to the madness i
also have this move
i think i'll start with this so oh but
then g5
huh
g5 i have to be very careful here
[Music]
bishop c6
there's g6 too
g6 is kind of crazy but maybe not too
crazy
i'll play g6 so the idea is to meet g5
with um with knight h5
um i have to always be aware of queen d4
hitting the knight
and these pawns are menacing why could
we connect for at any moment
that's another resource i take it
on my knight though
have to retreat
what else to do
this is looking really really ugly
but i'm still alive
not getting mated the issue now
i can't really take because of things i
forget
that feeling of deja vu hey it's gemano
i didn't even look i know it's shimano
what's up gemano welcome back
not really looking at chat this time but
i know it's you it's every month
uh i5 is terrifying
if i i want to take but my bishop's
pinned
or my bishop's undefended f6 is coming
if i take with epawn i can play bishop
c6 maybe
or bishop d8 bishop d8 might be the way
to go
and it's this game i'm uh i'm down on
time
it's like the opposite of the previous
game
okay only down about a minute
if i can trade i just want to trade and
not get mated
my two goals in life
if it takes takes i'm assuming the
bishop's gonna like try and i mean
bishop e3 could be really strong
in bishop e3 i take here here f6
so i might i might lose the exchange in
that line
that's a scary move too
hmm
robocalls sorry about that
okay forgot to put my phone in do not
disturb
i wonder if i can take i can't take
something gets hit
i could take a knife b5 maybe
okay
i still have some time to work with
and the pieces are just trash
this is pawn storm
have to take
okay so queen d2 is obvious plan
hmm
it's so hard to stop too
man how do i stop queen d2
let's go eric i'm trying but it's
difficult
[Music]
let's take first
i'm probably going to lose this
i see i see one idea of take side rook
c4 to h4
smart move
i'm still alive maybe
oh so i'm preparing queen f8
rook f3 is a big problem
rogue three f4 cover h3
it's difficult because i want to move
quickly but i'm on the verge of getting
mated
this is really nerve-wracking
i want this time i play king h7
play g5 first maybe no no that was a
mouse slip
ah
that's not good
let's do some hope with time
down the piece and down on time too
another bad move
ah
i don't see what to do
there goes my pieces ah oh wow
oh that was a close fight like even i
guess i survived the attack
rookie four was kind of an unfortunate
mouse slip but
that's all i get for spending so much
time good game
okay one to one i played well
i have to really have to improve on the
opening
i'll play i'll repeat the london because
the first game was kind of
it was definitely a good sign
and thank you brady corrigan stopping
for nine months
curious if my opponent my opponent could
have like theoretically
prepared this but probably not just
given that they're uh
he's thinking here also think first
thank you for subbing
aiden5225 appreciate that
okay this is nice i think so far
i'm realizing that like opening like
getting some opening in my comfort zone
is really important
because i was able to do it the first
game unable to do it the previous game
um i think it's clear actually
it's kind of clear that
my opponent hasn't done so much specific
preparation
which is making me inclined to play a
stafford but i'll probably i'll probably
just wait until the three minute portion
this is still prep the idea is after it
takes i play queen g4
i'm also trying to open the position so
i have the bishop here
oh i don't really enjoy eating souls
kind of on a diet
trying to to eat greens
and avoid unnecessary fats
but i'll try and make you proud
also tam fam sam
tam sam tan thanks for subbing
hello sorry i butchered your name
okay queen g4 is actually the last move
of my prep
i'm trying to actually remember what do
i do against queen e5
defending both pawns i assume bishop f4
queen here it's kind of some kind of
gambit i
guess
now we'll see what black does
and queen e5 what are my other options
there's bishop f4 queen i5 i take that
should be good for me
i feel like i've had this position like
maybe a few times in the past
and king king f8 was unexpected
now maybe there's some logic to it
let's start by taking
and then probably queen h4
and queen is comfy here if the light
moves i mate
i'm also preparing bishop e3
now this is a really nice position so i
won back the pawn i have the bishop here
it's pretty open black lost casting
rights
which could be relevant kind of going
into the middle game
because a rook will have a harder time
entering
queen h5 is very logical i'll play queen
b4
and then maybe bishop e2 with tempo
or just knight f3 bishop b2
and bishop can find a home
there's also this move
let's not waste any time
oh i forgot about that move ah
i should not have allowed that
wondering queen h4
queen h4 takes 28 not a f8
i take back it's interesting
let's do it
yeah the goal is to like just
pressure make my opponent think this is
kind of a tricky line like neither fate
i take
and then the knight the bishop they're
both pinned the rook is stuck
i guess there's queen f6 on that line we
could end up trading
the queen f65 queen e8
i guess there's b6 to prepare that
i'll go into it anyway and black's
probably coming out fine like b6
immediately
i was hoping i would have something
[Music]
something cool
i don't think i'm scared of this just be
nice to have the g-file
oh i could queenside castle here let's
do that
and then i'll get maybe a rook to d8
okay b6 expected there's also like this
idea
hmm
okay so this kind of goes back to the
point i was making earlier the fact that
this rook is stuck
g'day eric in from melbourne australia
along with
a viewer first time caller oh ah
wait i've seen you before though but
maybe first time cheer
i don't know i've been to melbourne it's
nice
it was warm g6
i wanted to win material
oh thanks everyone for subbing a few new
subs
appreciate it
huh and maybe i'm not winning anything
i really thought i was going to win
material
i want to get an e4 somehow
hmm wow so many people subbing
really appreciate it thanks people okay
let's play bishop f3
okay so the plan is to put the rook here
and then go after that pawn
and the a pawn
if king f6 i have f4 which is nice
and this pawn is undefendable except oh
maybe opponent
if i take there's this tricky tricky so
i have to play this
but now black is completely stuck i
think let's play h4
yeah the knight can't move and the rook
is stuck too
i could i could just promote
if the rug moves back i mate
yeah let's get the king here and then
[Music]
meet
okay plenty of time
okay
just have to take a breather
so the first three games white has been
dominating
every game let's go thanks everyone
colin roddy pushy pawn
rudy toss bye bedezza man
oh calling really gifted five subs oh i
didn't
even realize thanks calling rudy gifting
five subs
really appreciate that i guess that's
why the sub sound was happening
um okay let's mix up the opening i'm
gonna play
uh potentially a dragon
yeah accelerated dragon it's another
another one of these openings i keep up
my sleeve
just for special occasions
so we're going into some main line
bishop c4 is a main move
castling bishop b3 this line has been
played thousands
probably tens of thousands of times
h3 is probably also playable
actually wondering if i had d5 there
oh so opponents playing actually haven't
seen this before
um it looks playable i think d5 is
probably the way to go i'll admit i'm
out of theory
but it seems like my opponent is too and
peace links thanks for subbing
okay so we're we're halfway through the
blitz portion
and then it's gonna be eight games of
three minutes so this yeah this could be
a long match
but i'm energized i have the green tea
i took a long walk earlier got some
fresh air
and that gave me some energy some idea
of e5 here
there's also an idea night before which
i have a vague memory
is like possible
in these positions it avoids any knight
takes c6
let's do it
yeah i used to play like there's a
different line
like the classical variation of the
dragon where
this is like a go-to idea and you
preserve a nylon d5 as black
um yes i don't have bishop f5 here
you can still take my favorite black
opening oh the real bacon bits
i think someone someone was asking a
question earlier about accelerated
dragon
it's a tricky opening like even at a
high level
there's always new ideas popping up
this is the main drawback of of
accelerated dragon when i can play
marathi binds
which my opponent did not play this game
oh opponent still wants to attack me
though
confusing position um
okay let's start by calculating tactics
because i can take and play knight b6
attacking this and this
the queen on h6 looks scary
oh wow there's a crazy line takes
takes here and then knight f3
i take and then i'm almost getting mated
am i getting mated of queen d2 in that
line
king f1
wow i also have queen a5
huh i could just play this right away
and if takes i
take there's still queen h6
oh that's a mess
i mean takes takes that might be the
simplest and then e5
yeah i'm gonna probably avoid the mess
actually my opponent might take i think
here
because they might be calculating um
this line which is kind of confusing
i mean my intention is just to take back
with the king and whatever white does to
defend the bishop i play e5 probably
trade queens
yeah my queen's defended so i don't have
to worry about these checks
and there's no bishop d3 because that
would hang a knight
so let's play e5 and we'll get
we'll get kind of an equal position
trying to assess this and i have a bit
more center
with the only center pawn
an e-pawn could be a target though okay
let's start by taking
oh okay i think the bishop wants to
the bishop wants to chill on c6
and it'll be a nice kind of bishop pawn
duo
it's approximately equal but there's
still
still a lot of life in this position
with bishops of the same color we both
want our pawns on dark squares
which i'm doing a decent job of
at least with these pawns the only open
file is a d-file
so should probably fight for it
oh we could trade we could trade
everything
uh
i think i'll take
so unlike bishops of opposite color
bishops of
the same color have usually a higher
decisive
uh game ratio in the end game
um like there's more room to outplay the
opponents
[Music]
let's push idea b5 b4 and a5
and again it could just come down to
time
oh we could trade bishops too long this
but then then i can take
white could be left with a pawn weakness
not sure how relevant that is
play this friend to take the pawn so
there's a trick here if rook takes d8 i
take with check
and that's uh that should be a winning
end game for me
c3 good move
go for this this could fizzle
i'm trying to create some like weakness
on the queen side
rook d2 is now an idea
all right let's take and play rook b8
threatening rock b2
yeah these pawns are my white spawns
should be weaker than my pawns
going for a3 the a3 rook b2 is a nice
kind of construction
yeah why not king d3
it's king d1 actually
okay i want to bring the king in
okay looks like i'm winning a two in the
end of this
and importantly defending this pawn as
well
oh that's a tricky move
[Music]
to go for this
okay uh
am i promoting i'm close to promoting
uh i i gotta start playing quicker
that's tricky there we go
okay wow that was a hard fought end game
as a long endgame grind
um i think this position should
objectively be
a draw just white has to play a waiting
move
but time yeah time was relevant
okay so uh current match score is three
to one
hit him with the schneeb gambit what is
that
alexa what's a schneeberg gambit
sorry i'm not sure about it oh i'm not
sure either
oh thanks knight c8
i'll keep playing i'll keep playing the
same opening
because the first yeah the first two
games i was white
i've enjoyed h6 i've enjoyed life
okay let's uh control the center
so no london this game if i were to play
this and h6 would maybe just be
justified
[Music]
ooh cairo khan play c4
[Music]
why not
i'm just trying to play like objectively
the best moves
if that makes sense i'm gonna leave the
tension
maybe that will oh that probably wasn't
the best move cause i'm allowing this
and then
h6 is making sense
unfortunately yeah bishop f
huh that's also possible
i'm not entirely proud of this
probably knight c3
there is a line there's some line where
like white does this there's some
carlson on game um i think i'm still up
at tempo
like compared to that game
but okay we're just gonna have some
position
so i guess in some way it's kind of an
opening success for black
it's kind of like a reverse london
without this pond
also very caro con like
i'll play this so i'm not sure i'm not
sure if i want to do this or
fiancado
a32
actually let's play bishop e3
yeah i just want to play quick moves
keep everything under control
e5 is very reasonable
i play d5
now we could be trading down c5 is
interesting
knight d4 also possible
94
actually thinking about c5 bishop c7
then knight d4
but i give away the d5 square
i'll play knight d4 here
i spent a little bit too much time there
maybe a3
i'll just kind of hold my ground it's a
tense position
that's a good move
play queen b3 so queen b3 allows this or
this
if if knight d3 rookie
ed1 i think is okay
i guess there's knight f4
i mean maybe a simpler option if knight
d3 i just take it
and i play rook ad1
i can see the bishop here but there's
tricks in the end because when the
bishop moves i have c5 bishop big c5
knight takes c6
unleashing the rook
that's a decent move
okay let's control the d file at least
fight for the d
file envisioning bishop b6 ideas
some cool f4 ideas too
it's weird like if if something goes to
d7 f4 could potentially trap the knights
which would be very nice
i probably want to start with bishop f1
just so both rooks have more scope
expecting this
i guess one drawback of bishop f1 is a
bishop h5 that's probably not a huge
deal
just rip d2 and they'll have knight of
five ideas
i have a time advantage too and it seems
like all the white games
getting some lead on time which is nice
this is the second to last five minute
game
okay black taking to think um
that looks playable
i think i'll just take
i'll just take and chill like bishop
on and hold my ground
i've realized that if i just get a solid
position
and try and restrict my opponent um he's
very
susceptible to like taking a lot of time
when there's no
clear plans so i'm going to try and
exploit that as much as possible
it's not necessarily about like finding
my own plans
it's just about improving the position
and giving my opponent decisions
there's some tactical idea maybe
this could get messy bishop h6 bishop g2
some c5 idea too
i think a4 a4 is like a typical
positional move
it fixes this pawn but i think it did
help improve my queen
yes i no longer have bishop b6
that's a direct idea
okay there's a weird line i'm trying to
calculate bishop f8 bishop here like
here
takes takes takes and then all the rooks
are hanging
there's takes
wait i take and then defend i think it's
okay
let's do it
the worst case scenario i take with
knight and trade stuff
but i think queen takes is okay
okay now queen g3
expecting f6 and then knight f5
really pressuring the pawns and this is
exactly what i wanted just
some some nice momentum initiative
i maybe had this move but that's nice
getting the knight in
maybe i should have taken h6 when i had
the chance
play rook rookie three
oh this pawn is kind of is actually kind
of hanging
let me just defend it
okay knight's attacked
i'm considering this crazy move
because it allows black to fork me but i
think it's okay
i'm trying to invade g6
okay the question is if pawn takes
probably just knight g6
i'll take the bishop and win the pawn
take with rook
on the verge of winning on time
okay clean game
my only disappointment was not punishing
this this movie more
but uh i kept things controlled
okay let's go one more game
one more of five plus oh people can use
the format command
i hope there's mods there's probably
some mods in the chat
okay it's 9 p.m here so we're we're
about an hour into the match
and you have some more tea before again
um i think i'll i'll repeat the dragon
i mean i like the opening um i'm
probably not going to play time olive
again
because yeah that that line was actually
really annoying when there's g3 line
against time on
off opponent considering maybe this move
or this move actual london 3
am bits oh oh it's actual oh are you in
london
i guess i've only had one london so far
that that first game my opponent has
been avoiding it since
i actually looked at this line recently
i had this line probably in some leeches
game
i'd reviewed this and then this okay d3
with d3 i'll just complete development
like this
probably going for the double fiend keto
the bishop is now wait what
what i'm not holding down any arrow keys
am i colorblind this is blue right
or wait i'm so confused
did leachates just change the default of
the
wait i'm what
everything's blue now unless i'm not
seeing things
correct it used to be green
or am i going insane control
how do i make it red
i can only i used to be able to make it
red but i know only blue and yellow
usually it was like alt or control or
shift
and the shift keys aren't stuck i don't
think i guess we're stuck with blue and
yellow now
what is this
okay there's three possibilities
possibility number one we just just
updated
and there's no more green
possibility number two david blaine
behind you oh
uh probably but he's invisible so
i don't want to bother him yeah
possibility too is like something's
wrong with the keyboard something's
stuck but i can't figure out what it is
don't let the arrows distract you
but there are circles too circles and
arrows
in possibility three i'm just i
randomly went colorblind and this is
actually green even though it looks like
blue
play h6 here
thankfully i'm still up on time
i've been more perplexed about the
arrows in the position which is probably
not a
maybe it's an okay thing like position
solid
i'm gonna have to get used to this now
a position i really can't complain
everything
literally everything's defended let's go
rosa oh
let's go cooch is off gambit thanks for
subbing
appreciate that
okay so this changes things because now
there's more scope along the diagonal
there's some like f4 idea
oh there's a chief g5s or green arrows
i missed i like blue oh
i i mean i don't mind the blue i just
kind of
feels like i just lost a friend
hm 94 is kind of interesting
is there's c4
i wonder if i can play c4 myself
allowing knight d6 which i shouldn't
allow 96.
you might have sticky keys enabled so
all is being held down
oh but i don't
i'll troubleshoot between games maybe
let's focus that was a good move
i want to play another four
[Music]
97
97 wait 97 c4 knight f4
i have six i take oh no neither four is
hanging
f5 i mean the first thought was g5
let's look at c4 one more time c496
workout fate
takes takes i lose a pawn
hmm i really don't know what to do here
maybe rook f8 immediately maybe this is
the way to go
it's a sad move but there's so many
lines where i play rook f8 anyway
because knight comes here
and this actually gives me an option if
like does play c4 let's say knight b4
knight f6 i could play king
chades and i'm not getting forked oh but
there's nike seven
i might just have to deal with that
i mean there's some downsides of c4 oh
c4 i can take in
wait a minute that's complicated
because if i take take take and i lose
h6 and i'm probably getting mated there
but maybe there's some potential to take
on b2 with the queen
96 anyway
okay
go for this i'm just trying to simplify
yeah now i lost the bishop pair but
this is really not so bad
i mean it's probably preferable for
black
a little bit because this bishop's a bit
out of play and this bishop is stuck
i have the a file oh that's a good move
though
wondering if i can play
play this move
it takes takes
eventually i want to play this use uh
a pawn to create weaknesses zip t was
redeemed
good timing very good timing uh okay
let's take because there's a pin
but this is a pin
oh i'm just losing a piece
i might just be losing a piece i didn't
see that
if i take take there this is also a pin
okay so i'm down the piece and i'm down
on time
i feel like i had this situation before
but there's hope like i have pawns for
the
i have two pawns for it two pawns for a
night
um somewhat safe king
rook d3
now let's not blunder anything i want to
play this move
difficult position
oh white's on the flag probably
okay the opponents
got maybe a bit too complacent there
wait what just happened
okay some key is stuck but i don't know
what key it is
but i just use the arrow key oh that's
so weird
wait what key is stuck do i press all
the keys wait okay let me
let me fix something i'm gonna press all
the keys
you